Ruby, you have slayed
your look.
It smells like canned soup
in here.
Hi.
-How are you?
-I'm good. Good luck.
Hi.
Ugh,
there's nothing gluten-free.
How long
have you been diabetic?
I'm not diabetic.
You can't… eat sugar.
Gluten, Adam. Not glucose.
Does anyone else…
like the smell
of their own farts?
You told me
to ask questions.
Quite nervous. It's hot.
Take your fucking jacket
off, then.
Quickly.
Fuck yeah.
So, are you guys excited
about going to France?
Not really.
I get coach sick.
Oh, I wish I could go.
I've got to go to a wedding
in Nigeria.
Isn't it illegal to be gay
in Nigeria?
Yeah, it is. But no one
knows I am there, so…
I didn't know
it was illegal.
Yeah, it's no big deal.
It sounds like a big deal.
We can talk about it later.
Adam, how is your dad?
Erm, I don't know. I haven't
seen him for a while.
My parents are separated.
Yeah. Yeah, I heard. Sorry.
Well, my mum's having a baby
with Ola's dad,
which is kind of weird
because we used to date
and now we're kind of like
actual siblings.
Maybe
don't tell people that.
Pretty weird, dude.
How do you feel about it?
New family,
baby and stuff...
It's a big adjustment
'cause I'm an only child,
but I'm trying to be
more adult.
Yeah, I think Ola's
finding it hard, too.
After her mum died
and her sister's gone off
to university,
it's just been her
and her dad, so…
Maybe you can
help each other out.
Did I say the wrong thing?
No.
That's very astute,
actually.
-Holy shit!
-What?
Kim Kardashian is having
another surrogate baby.
She is so bold.
I can't believe it.
Don't you think
it's weird how...
the last surrogate was
never in the show?
I watch The Kardashians.
With my mum.
Well, well, well.
So, ultimate question:
Khloé pre-
or post-revenge body?
-Pre.
-I totally agree.
Because
it's so much more relatable.
-Big time.
-Yeah.
I think I'm starting to get
the whole Adam thing.
Yeah.
He grows on you, doesn't he?
Hello, hello, hello, hi.
That was fun.
Are you guys going back
to Ruby's now?
I've never actually been
to Ruby's house.
Really?
You guys have been seeing
each other for a while now?
Anyway, this was nice.
Adam, text me
once you've watched
the Kylie Does New York
spinoff, yeah?
Ok, bye bye.
Oh, erm, bye.
Hey, I think we were walking
in the same direction, but…
Yeah.